hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game we are taking a short
break once again from the capablanca
saga to give you a very nice game from
the capablanca Memorial Tournament that
was played in Havana Cuba
and the tournament ended but we're gonna
disclose the results after we check out
this game here vastly von Schuch faces
the top seed in the tournament Indian
Grandmaster Bhaskar an early man
if once you've already won the Coppa
Blanca memorial seven times I think no
one wanted more times than Chucky here
and this is his eighth attempt at the
title now as you all know capablanca
died in 1942 and the distr namond
started being held in his honor
ever since night in 1962 so some 20
years after his death and the first
winner of the capablanca Memorial in
1962 was none other than Miguel Nye Dorf
and I think I think no one wanted more
times than Chucky so far but I will have
to check on that not really sure so like
I said fifty fourth edition being played
in the Libre Hotel in Cuba Havana let's
check out this very nice game if I chuck
has the white pieces and as the d4 pawn
is already on the board he opens with d4
we have d 6e for now and now g6 Audubon
goes for the world for the modern
defense we have c4 Chuckie grabs as much
Center as possible as Adi banana for the
moment is not fighting for it I push up
to g7 now comes Knight to c3 with Knight
G to E - now I move laQuan Liam sorry
Knight to c3 c5 and now Knight G to E -
I move upon Liam used against the Magnus
Carlsen in the 2012 World blitz final
Coulson was able to win that game with
Knight to c6 by audubon and now d5
grabbing space in the center we have
nice to a5 and now there have been a few
moves tried here well only my a1 move
was known to be played in this position
but Chuckie goes for rook to be 1 and
this is now a new move in the position
just you know
preemptively moving this rook from this
diagonal and preparing b4 so you could
say that Chuckie came prepared for this
game so already on move 7 a new game on
our hands with Knight to f6 preparing to
Castle as the knight is now here you
have to figure out how to
well how to castle finish your
development you could've og3 but that's
not not recommended Chuckie goes for
night 2 G 3 prepares Bishop to e2 and
castling we have castles and the now
comes the Bishop to e2 ecigs challenging
chalky strong center with castles by von
Schuch ich after Sun d5 with C capture
Sun d5 and now just a 6 so similar a
similar structure for example to the
Benoni if example this Knight was on f3
and let's say if this night was on d7
but it's it's not so Chuckie goes for B
for the move he prepared and now now you
have to decide whether we want to
capture immediately or you want to go
for Knight to d7 a move which Audubon
went for and now it discovers an attack
towards a chocolate night with Queen to
d2 defending and the now comes seek
actress on b4 and now Knight the d1
there's always time to pick up the
before pawn there's no way to defend it
and now comes h5 preparing h4 where
event you would have to go all the way
to h1 with his knight and even though
you know Chuckie doesn't mind going back
with the night if you remember his
famous saying from the I believe Jupiter
trade wise Festival where he said that
the hardest move to find is with the
night back and here indeed you can go
for Queen captures and before and after
h4 gonna take one it is it is possible
but Chuckie doesn't like his Knight on
h1 he instead finds a super active move
he plays Bishop captures on h5 so he
offers a piece for for a very nice
attack and here are the one has to
decide what to do of course he can
capture if he captures then you get
Knight captures on h5 with some very
nice threats you of course want to
eliminate the dark square Bishop and
without the dark square Bishop there
will be well very little black can do to
oppose Chucky's light square Bishop so
here you could go Queen h4 Knight
capture skin captures now Knight - III
prepare Knight a5 check to win the Queen
so of course a black would have to do
something to prevent that let's say
Knight c5 and now you have 4 pieces on
the Queen side and the Chuck is
attacking on the King side not something
you want to do g3 can be played and here
it would be just a very hard position to
hold for black like the Queen captures
here you can get real
captors here now the Rope can also join
the attack lukkage for and it's just
gonna be very hard to play this for
black odd-even who doesn't want to go
this sorry bond is an attacker he
doesn't want he doesn't like being
attacked so he declines the bishop
sacrifice and he goes Knight to c4 first
he attacks
Chucky's Queen and Queen captures on b4
saying okay you capture my bishop I'm
gonna capture your night I grabbed a
nice pawn your King's pawn structure is
all messed up but a diamond just
continues to develop and b5 he says okay
I don't mind being down a pawn or two
I'm just gonna get a nice active game
Chuck he goes back with Bishop to e2 and
now comes Knight to c5 Bishop captures
on c4 that is a very strong night here B
chapters and now comes well you could go
for Queen captures but then you have to
deal with some Bishop to d7 tricky ideas
here
so instead eventual first tries to go
Bishop to b2 the dark square Bishop
Audubon has in g7 is the black strongest
piece now so of course Jackie wants to
trade it down and here it's not the most
precise way to play here he allows a
team on a lot of activity
everyone goes night to d3 attacks the
Queen and the bishop with Queen to a3
and now just the knight character son
beat you with Knight captures on b2 and
now of course c3 and all of a sudden
Audubon has a very strong protected pass
pawn on c3 Knight to c4 now going after
the d6 pawn and now Queen to c7 saying
okay you can't capture because I'm gonna
capture your knight on c4 and if Knight
captures then I'm just gonna go see to
and then were you gonna go with the roof
if you move the rook then I get Bishop
to d7 and again Bishop to b5 will be
very strong as a threat at some point
and it's just a very strong backbone for
black so after the screen to c7 move we
have
Knight to a5 by chalky taking care of
these very important squares preparing
Knight to c6
we have rook to b8 and then out comes
Luke captures we have Queen captures and
now Knight to c6 so here you have to
decide what do you want to do here the
strongest line of defense for Audubon is
just Queen to be - it's a very strong
move that will put a lot of pressure on
charges back rank and here after Queen
captures on d4 and see
- it's already very dangerous she's
already threatening pawn to see one you
have to go 92 - the Fendi one square and
now you have this line but it's a when
you have to decide to go for this line
it's really impossible to see it it's
it's a really disgusting Engine line so
I'll just show it just to show that
there was a a better line than the one
Audubon played but it's better to g4u
threatened to remove the defender of the
C 1 square so of course
Chucky would have to go F 3 and now
Queen b6 check it's really just a really
disgusting line and here you can go King
H 1 because if you go King H 1 it's well
it's just bad Queen B 5 wins the game
for black there's too much pressure
the knight is under attack you can't
really move the knight even if you move
it you think or something like Knight to
the g3 but - then I can just play Queen
captures on f1 captures and then bring
another queen into the game so all our
lines are winning here for black so the
point is after this f3 move and Queen to
b6 check you can't go here you have to
block with rook F - you can't go 94 as
the bishop and queen covered the d4
square and here black would just get a
draw by repetition Queen B 1 check rook
goes back we have two Queen b6 check
rook F 2 and the Queen b1 check it's
just like I said a super disgusting
engine line but I just want to show it
that it does exist other one didn't go
for that he went Queen to b5 and now
just Queen captures on b6 we have c2 but
now just Queen to c7 now there's no
Queen and b2 to threaten want to see one
and bring your Queen enter game so Chuck
he just goes Queen to c7 and he creates
some new threats he's also keeping an
eye on the pawn but also Knights the e7
check would win the bishop on c8 so you
do have to defend it Bishop to f6 by or
even taking well the control of d7
Square and now comes Knight to a7 and
here it's again a very dangerous
position where I will ask you to pause
the video your queen is under attack and
of course your Bishop is under attack
twice by the knight end by the Queen so
how do you defend here feel free to
pause the video and try to find the best
defensive move for black I know I don't
ask you to find offensive moves very
often but it is also very important so
I'll give
a couple of seconds for those of you who
found Quinta Quinta b7 it does get your
queen out of the way and also defends
the bishop here and it is also what
Audubon played but it is also the move
that loses the game we're just gonna
show why
here are the one played Queen to b7 and
then Chuck he just played Queen captures
on b7 Bishop captures on b7 and here
rook the c1 he's now gonna win the c2
pawn and it's well it's all over he's up
three pawns there's really not much
audubon can do here but for those of you
that found instead of Queen - b7 Queen
to d7 this is the way to defend and it
is a way for for black to maybe maybe
save this game after Queen captures on
b7 and this this now doesn't work if you
go Queen captures on b7 you get just
Bishop captures and now rook the c1
doesn't work because the bishop from d7
can guard the pawn we have bishop here
guarding the pawn and now next move
you're just gonna attack the rook and
you're gonna win the exchange so this
way black would even be winning so after
this Queen to d7 move you will not be
able to trade you're gonna have to go
something like Queen to c5 gonna have to
keep the pressure there should be seven
you can you can go Queen e3 and the game
continues where black keeps his very
strong passed pawn and c2 but here are
the bond went Queen to b7 and Chuckie
just said okay Queen captures with
Bishop characters and now comes look to
c1 so now there's no way to defend your
c2 pawn with Bishop to g5 and now rook
captures on c2 we have f5 by black not
just rook to c7 attacking the bishop
bishop to EA 8 and now tonight back to
c6 introducing the night into the game
Bishop FA F for going after the rook but
not look to a7 just going after the pawn
also maybe rook t97 check will threaten
some nasty ideas so Audubon takes care
of it with Bishop captures D captures
and now rook to e8 going after the pawn
rook captures an a6 but now just F
captures on e4 with rook to e4 and it
was in this position unmoved 37 that
mascara Audubon resigned the game and
truly a well-deserved victory
for for Vasily lunchable who would this
victory gets his eighth eighth throw of
the trophy in the capablanca Memorial
Tournament so this is his eighth win a
time that he won the tournament here
you're simply done too much material if
dressing like rook c8 was just going to
defend the pawn now again you're gonna
lose this pawn there's no defense
against Knight captures if you go back
the fender with the rugged and white can
just start pushing the C pawn or if you
capture you're just down too many points
it's really just an easy game you're
gonna capture this pawn and bring your
king and it's a game over so after Luke
today for admin resigned the game and we
do have the stats for this again sorry I
forgot to prepare it let me just fix
that
there we go I don't know why I left the
standings of the previous tournament
that we were showing so here are the
standings after this a wonderful double
round-robin six players first place of
Ashley watch with seven points then two
players with six points Samuel 7 the
only player who defeated the vastly one
to be in this tournament and also a
third place David Anton we ha row fourth
place we have the local Cuban
Grandmaster Carlos Daniel albornoz
Cabrera then Bhaskar on a diamond in
fifth place the highest rated player in
the tournament only player like we said
rated over 2,700 but it just wasn't his
tournament maybe he just well maybe he
didn't get used to the climate or
quickly enough and then you reconcile us
with all in last place also a local
Grandmaster and I mean that is a thing
sometimes players will even arrive at a
at a tournament site maybe even two
weeks in advance well not today maybe
since you know it's a you know it's it's
a faster world we live in so you maybe
they can't afford to go to a tournament
place on another continent or or you
know somewhere where the climate is
different two weeks in advance to get
you stood but before they it was a you
know a normal a normal happening so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
like I said ate the victory for vastly
want you who who knows maybe maybe he'll
get to 10 which would be really exciting
and I thought it you know it's we are
covering the Capablanca saga so why not
cover a nice game from the capablanca me
more
tournament I would like to thank
Frederico savant and our own waffle art
Francis Daughtry and his sons felix
rhyme and kenneth mckay of scotland for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too in my previous videos
seiran thank you for watching and I will
see you soon most likely continuing the
capablanca saga but also checking up on
your suggestions and and such and just a
nice you know feedback on the on the
chest manga we are still going through
all the emails there are so many of them
and we are still just arranging them so
we can use them for later but you will
be notified accordingly thank you all I
will see you soon have an excellent rest
of your day